E
ONLY PLACE WE SEE HISTORIC BEAT
DOWN THIS WEEK WE'RE LESS THAN
24 HOURS FIRST POLLS CLOSING IN
THE MID TERM ELECTIONS AND
REPUBLICANS ARE CHARGING FOR THE
FINISH LINE.
ARE WE LOOKING AT BUN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST RED WAVES IN AMERICAN
HISTORY?
WELL, IN 2010, OBAMA LOST
DEMOCRATS 63 SEATS IN THE HOUSE.
IN 1994, CLINTON DROPPED 54.
IN 2018, TRUMP LOST 0.
40.ALL OF THEM HAD HIGHER APPROL
RATINGS THAN BIDEN RIGHT NOW.
WHAT HAPPENS TOMORROW?
ANYTHING OVER 40 HOUSE SEATS IS
A BIG WAVE.
THE FIRST POLLS CLOSE AT AROUND
7:00.
AND BILL HEMMER TELLS ME IF
REPUBLICANS PICK UP AT LEAST TWO
OF THE THREE HOUSE SEATS IN
VIRGINIA THAT MEANS WE ARE
LOOKING AT A MASSIVE WAVE.
DON'T LISTEN TO THE LIES THEY
ARE SPEWING THAT THIS COULD TAKE
DAYS OR DAYS YOU KNOW, TO KNOW
WHO WON.
THIS IS TOTAL B.S.
A WAVE LIKE THIS WE SHOULD KNOW
THAT NIGHT, BASICALLY, WHO WON
THE SENATE AND THE HOUSE
ANYTHING THAT HAPPENS WEDNESDAY
INTO THURSDAY IS GRAVY.
THE POLLS SHOW DEMOCRATS SINKING
AND REPUBLICANS RISING.
DEMOCRATS BLEW EVERY LEAD THEY
HAD.
17% OF BLACKS SAY THEY WILL VOTE
FOR REPUBLICAN.
THAT'S DOUBLE WHAT THE
REPUBLICANS SAW FOUR YEARS AGO.
DEMOCRATS LEAD WITH LATINOS HAS
SHRUNK IN HALF SINCE AUGUST.
MEANWHILE, SUBURBAN WHITE WOMEN,
A GROUP I KNOW VERY WELL ARE
RUNNING AWAY FROM DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE TIRED OF SHELLING OUT
$100 TO FILL UP THEIR JEEP GRAND
CHEROKEES.
DEMOCRAT ARE LOSING BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT LISTENING TO VOTERS.
BUT DON'T TAKE IT FROM ME.
>> I'M A LOYAL DEMOCRAT BUT I AM
NOT HAPPY, I JUST THINK THAT WE
ARE, YOU KNOW, WE DID NOT LISTEN
TO VOTERS IN THIS ELECTION AND I
THINK WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A BAD
NIGHT.
WHEN VOTERS TELL YOU OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT THEY
CARE MOSTLY ABOUT THE ECONOMY,
LISTEN TO THEM.
STOP TALKING ABOUT DEMOCRACY
BEING AT STAKE.
DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING SO MUCH
ABOUT WHAT ELECTIONS MEAN.
I MEAN, VOTERS ARE TOLD US WHAT
THEY WANTED TO HEAR AND I DON'T
THINK DEMOCRATS HAVE REALLY
DELIVERED.
>> I FELT THERE WAS A MOMENT
WHERE IT FELT LIKE HEY, MAYBE WE
CAN TALK ABOUT ABORTION AND
DEMOCRACY TURNS OUT THAT WAS
FOOL'S GOLD.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE SITTING ON A
WHITE HOT STOVE OF ECONOMIC PAIN
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
GOING TO DO FOR THEM.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE RIGHT.
WHEN INFLATION FIRST STARTED
RAMPING UP THEY SAID IT WAS
TRANSITORY AND RUSSIA'S FAULT
AND BIG OIL AND REMEMBER BIG
MEAT?
NOW THEY ARE OUT OF PEOPLE TO
BLAME.
TELLING YOU TO SUCK IT UP AND
EAT CHEF BOYARDEE.
>> WHAT DO YOU PLAN TO DO HELP
SOLVE INFLATION PROBLEM.
>> I GREW UP IN A FAMILY WHERE
IF THE GAS PRICE WENT UP THE
FOOD BUDGET WENT DOWN.
BY THIS TIME WEEK WE WOULD BE
EATING CHEF BOYARDEE.
THAT'S WHAT FAMILIES HAVE TO DO.
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT JUST THE
HOUSE.
SMART MONEY SAY REPUBLICANS TAKE
THE SENATE.
WINNING THE MAJORITY BY 53 SEATS
TO 47.
THAT'S WHAT REAL CLEAR HAS IT AT
RIGHT NOW.
NOW A FEW MONTHS AGO DEMOCRATS
WERE CERTAIN THEY COULD HOLD THE
SENATE SO WHAT HAPPENED?
WELL, THE CANDIDATES THEY ARE
RUNNING ARE THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
PEOPLE WANT.
LET'S START WITH FETTERMAN IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
DEMOCRATS WANTED A GUY WHO
CHASED AN INNOCENT UNARMED BLACK
MAN WITH A SHOTGUN TO BE THEIR
NEXT SENATOR.
NOW, IF OZ HAD EVER DONE THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE MADE HIM WEAR A
WHITE HOOD DURING THE DEBATE.
NOW, HE HAD THE LEAD FOR MOST OF
THE RACE, FETTERMAN, BUT NOW THE
RACE IS DEAD EVEN.
AND OZ IS SURGING AND IS NOW
BEATING FETTERMAN IN FIVE OUT OF
THE LAST SEVEN POLLS TAKEN.
THAT DEBATE KILLED FETTERMAN'S
HOPES.
SAME THING HAPPENED IN GEORGIA.
THE RACE IS TIED.
WALKER WAS 6 POINTS DOWN IN
OCTOBER.
AND THE DEMOCRATS THREW
EVERYTHING THEY HAD AT THIS GUY.
OVER $100 MILLION IN REALLY
DIRTY ATTACKS.
WALKER IS RUNNING THROUGH THE
TAPE AND REVEREND RAPHAEL
WARNOCK WAS EXPOSED AS A RACE
BAGHTS SLUM LORD WHO HATES
CRIMES AND HAS NO ANSWERS ON
CRIME AND INFLATION.
MANDELA BARNES IN WISCONSIN IS A
LOT LIKE WARNOCK EXPECT HE HAS A
LOT LESS MONEY AND NO REVEREND
BEFORE HIS NAME.
RON JOHNSON TOOK THE LEAD AT THE
END OF SEPTEMBER AND NEVER LOST
IT.
HE IS UP 3 POINTS AND HAS BEEN
UP SIX OF THE LAST POLLS TAKEN.
THAT'S A SENATE SEAT I'M NOT
WORRIED ABOUT LOSING.
JOHNSON IS RUNNING THE HUNTER
BIDEN.
WHEN HE WINS IT BECOMES THE JOE
BIDEN INVESTIGATION.
THE ARIZONA SENATE RACE THE
CLOSEST ONE.
ACCURATE MARK KELLY HAS HAD THE
LEAD THE ENTIRE TIME.
BLAKE MASTERS, WHO WE LIKE A
LOT, NEVER HAD THE MONEY KELLY
DID, BUT IS HE CLOSING HARD AS
HECK AND IS ONLY DOWN ONE POINT.
WITH A LOT OF MOMENTUM.
IS IT KEY SENATE RACE AND IF
MASTERS WINS, THAT MEANS THIS IS
A RED WAVE SITUATION.
POLLING IS TOUGH IN ARIZONA FOR
SOME REASON.
I CAN'T FIGURE IT OUT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO LEARN
A LOT TOMORROW.
THE NEVADA SENATE RACE ISN'T
GETTING A LOT OF TRACTION, BUT
THIS IS ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
PICK UP ANOTHER SEAT.
ADAM LAXALT IS RUNNING STRONG
WITH HISPANICS AND IS NOW AHEAD
OF A REALLY LACKLUSTER DEMOCRAT
CORTEZ MASTO BY ABOUT THREE
POINTS.
THIS RACE HAS GONE BACK AND
FORTH SINCE SEPTEMBER WITH A LOT
OF LEAD CHANGES BUT LAXALT IS
FINISHING STRONG.
GAS PRICES ARE RIDICULOUSLY HIGH
IN NEVADA AND ARE KILLING THE
DEMOCRAT THERE.
IT LOOKS LIKE REPUBLICANS HAVE
MOMENTUM IN THAT RACE.
ONE OF THE SLEEPERS IS NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
RIGHT?
BET YOU DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT THAT
ONE THE REPUBLICAN BOLDUC CAME
FROM NINE POINTS FROM BEHIND IN
A MONTH AND A HALF.
IT'S BASICALLY STATIS
PARTICULARLY EVEN.
JUST A POINT AND AND A HALF
BEHIND NOW.
IF WE ARE TALKING RED TSUNAMI,
REPUBLICANS PICK UP A SENATE
SEAT IN COLORADO.
THAT'S A LONG SHOT BUT WE WILL
KNOW TUESDAY NIGHT WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT.
I SEE REPUBLICANS HOLDING
PENNSYLVANIA AND WISCONSIN AND
PICKING UP GEORGIA, ARIZONA, AND
NEVADA.
THAT WOULD MAKE IT 53 REPUBLICAN
SENATE SEATS AND IF WE'RE
TALKING BLOOD MOON TYPE OF RED
WAVE, WE COULD GRAB NEW
HAMPSHIRE WHICH WOULD MAKE IT
54.
BIG GOVERNOR'S RACE IN ARIZONA,
OUR FRIEND KARI LAKE LOOKS LIKE
SHE HAS GOT.
THIS SHE HAS BEEN AHEAD FOR A
MONTH AND A HALF AND HOBBS IS A
CATASTROPHE.
AFRAID TO DEBATE AND FRAMED HER
OPPONENT FOR BURGLARY COMMITTED
BY ILLEGAL AND SHE HELD A MOCK
SLAVE AUCTION BUT THE MEDIA
DOESN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
ONLY WHAT IS IN BRETT
KAVANAUGH'S YEARBOOK THAT'S WHAT
COUNTS.
GEORGIA'S GOVERNOR RACE STACEY
ABRAMS CAREER IS OVER AFTER
TUESDAY.
BRIAN KEMP AHEAD BY ABOUT 8, HAS
NEVER TRAILED THE ENTIRE TIME.
STACEY IS GOING TO LOSE AND SAY
IT'S STOLEN AND PROBABLY GET A
JOB TEACHING AT HARVARD NEXT TO
BRIAN STELTER AND BILL DE
BLASIO.
THAT'S WHERE DEMOCRATS FAIL UP
TO.
NEW YORK IS MUCH CLOSER THAN IT
APPEARS.
GOVERNOR KATHY HOCHUL THE
ACCIDENTAL GOVERNOR, YOU
REMEMBER CUOMO GOT ME TOOD SO
SHE JUST FOUND HER WAY INTO THAT
SEAT, SHE HAS BEEN GETTING A LOT
OF LAST-MINUTE CPR FROM CROOKED
AND KAMALA AND BILL CLINTON EVEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
NOW, THE POLLS SAY SHE IS UP 7.
BUT THIS RACE IS A TOSS-UP.
AND IF ANYBODY REMEMBERS THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE IN NEW JERSEY
LAST YEAR THAT REPUBLICAN JACK
WAS DOWN 14 POINTS AND ENDED
UNJUST LOSING BY A HAIR.
NOW, THESE POLLS ALWAYS UNDER
ESTIMATE REPUBLICANS SO KEEP
THAT IN MIND.
CRIME IS ON THE BALLOT HERE IN
NEW YORK AND WE HOPE THE RED
WAVE TOUCHES THE EMPIRE STATE.
DESANTIS IS CRUISING TO VICTORY
IN FLORIDA.
NOT EVEN CLOSE ENOUGH TO PUT
THERE ON THE SCREEN IT'S A RUN
AWAY.
MOVE OVER TO MICHIGAN WHERE
TUDOR DIXON IS MAKING THIS A
RACE.
GRETCHEN WHITMER IS ONLY UP 4.
BUT THIS, AGAIN IS, LIKE NEW
YORK.
IT'S A TOTAL TOSS-UP.
GRETCHEN IS AN UNLIKEABLE LIAR
WITH A SCARY STARE AND SHE CAN'T
EVEN ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
COVID.
LITERALLY SHE CANNOT ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
WATCH THIS.
>> I'M SORRY, [BLEEP] DID I DO
THAT WHEN I TOUCHED